Guess who is in the Keuf Magazine cover again?
-Hey, look. Handless drive.
-STOP IT!!!
I order you that you had better be safe, after transferring to the new station.
Go to Marseille.
Marseille in the south?
Music: L'Algérino - "Va Bene"
Get used to it?
Yes.
Didn't I mean you like this place?
Don't be so serious.
I've been callous in the Special Police Squad before.
Hey! Pull over!
Are you crazy? You just hit a cop!
He wanted to stand on the center of the road.
Is that car from his house?
I won't fine you if you take that taxi back.
How about grouping into a team?
Just like Bad Boy.
Music: The Black Eyed Peas - "Pump It"
Is that real?
This's the amazing car in Marseille.
Then no shifter?
You make me have pressure. Stop doing this, or I can't concentrate.
Move. I'll drive.
Music: The Black Eyed Peas - "Pump It"
WE HAVE AN EMERGENCY!!!
We finally have this way done!
We now have a big trouble.
Wanna play with me?
The goddamn Italians.
Bring it on.
This mission is to
Get Mafias.
"The craziest taxi driver"
Recently, we have a suspected Italian called Rachid.
*Wilhelm Scream*
"5-time horsepower"
We have to repair this car.
I want to back on the road.
I love you!
Wow, he's really stupid!
*screaming*
I calm down!
Whoa, whoa, whoa!
-No, no, no, no, no!
-Stop messing with this guy. (x2)
No matter what, just give me a dozen.
Pre-out on April 7 in Marseille
Out nationally on April 11